On poursuit la discussion avec
Docteur qui est avec nous. La
question est : pourquoi ça ne se
fait pas plus? Est-ce que les
orthopédistes voulaient garder
leur pouvoir, leurs clients,
c'est parce qu'on n'y avait pas
pensé?
- C'est une question justement
des cultures. On parle souvent
de plus de médecins, il faut
aussi plus d'accès aux services
et mieux redistribuer les tâches
entre tous et chacun. Ce
programme que vous avez vu
représente bien une réalité,
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui est sorti de mon chapeau. On
avait des projets de validation
au début de 2009. En 2016, on a
implanté le plan communautaire.
Ces physio thérapeute en
pratique autonome, il faut le
dire, peuvent avoir jusqu'à 2000
patients par année chacun.
Nous sommes 350 orthopédistes au
Québec. On ne peut pas dou
le nombre d'ortho ni le nombre
de cas qu'on voi0
physio, donnez-moi 3 % des
physio au Québec et on peut
aller a.
- Que vous soyez entendus!
Est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de cas
où la personne n'a même pas
d'avoir un orthopédiste à
la fin? Un truc à l'épaule, au
genou. Donc un physiothérapeute?
- Pas tout, mais 75 % de nos
patients ne sont pas liés à la
pratique de l'orthopédiste.
Quand il rentre, nous sommes
capables de les voir rapidement
et de les rediriger vers le bon
service.
On va juste organiser le
désordre. On veut organiser un
service, le patient va être
traité et s'il a besoin de
services spécialisés, on veut
réagir vite. S'il a besoin d'un
orthopédiste, on va contacter
l'orthopédiste va pouvoir le
apidement. Ça va
désengorger le système.
- Mais pourquoi ça ne se fait
pas dans tous les hôpitaux duQu?
- Au-delà de la culture. Le
ministère et comme le Titanic.
Les gens sont là pour faire la
gestion des affaires courantes.
Ces modèles, on l'a validé en
2013 et on l'a i
qu'il y a des projets pilote qui
vont se faire encore, mais on a
déjà fait des projets pilote.
- Il faut envoyer cette entrevue
au ministre. Il faut que
quelqu.
- On veut que le public soit au
courant qu'il y a des façons de
faire  ait accès à un
service de qualité. L'accès
à un thérapeute et
approuvé depuis 40 ans.
Tout ce qu'on veut, c'est qu'on
récupère 3 % des physio qui sont
la au Québec, qui sont la,
afficher des postes, changeant
les façons de faire. Il y a unen
libère un orthopédiste d'une
pratique en clinique, il
pourrait aller en salle
d'opération. Si on change notre
mode de fonctionnement. Un
orthopédiste qui assiste à un
collègue, ça libère une
infirmière.
- Escalier physiothérapeut
veulent aller travailler dans
tous les hôpitaux ou veulent
rester en clinique?
- Ils sont compétents et
connaissant dans leur matière.
On doit valorise
connaissances. On a des
programmes maintenant de
maîtrise professionnelle à
l'université pou
gens. Et ceux qui sont en mode
pratique avancée dans le réseau,
le temps moyen entre être en
pratique avec un orthopédiste
pour l'accès direct, c'est
environ quatre mois. Après, ils
sont fonctionnels. Pour protéger
les professionnels et les
patients, on a établi des
niveaux de sécurité pour les
patients. On a toujours un
orthopédiste disponible.
des moyens
électroniques. On peut regarder
des radiographies à distance et
discuter. Il y a des systèmes
sécurisés qu'on peut utiliser
irectement avec
un patient même si on n'est pas
présent physiquement. Tout ça
est à petite échelle, mais pour
un programme, il
faut aller vers les ministère et
ça déborde un peu de notre
dossier.
- Je vous promets que je vais
poser la question aux deux
ministre Dubé. C'est un travail
d'équipe. Il n'y a pas que le
médecin. Je soupçonne que les
médecins n'étaient pas tous
aussi ouverts que vous ado
cette pratique. Le
physiothérapeute en fait un bout
et vous faites les cas urgents.
- On a tendance
des jeunes pour nous aider.
Donnez-moi de physio et trois
infirmières
rouler ma clinique. Le boulot,
c'est toujours le médecin et on
n'a pables.bles.bles.bles.bles..
a ne
changera rien dans la réalité
des listes d'attente. Quand on
autonome, autonome, autonome, aa
change complètement la donne.
- Il faut que je vous laisse,
mais c'est impressionnant.
Voulait laisser autonome, il
travaille et il voit les gens. s
ont à faire. Merci beaucoup.